Сполучені Штати вже формують нову стратегію дій щодо Донбасу.
І Вашингтон підтримає територіальну цілісність України "не тільки на словах, а й на ділі".
Про це заявив глава української делегації у Тристоронній контактній групі щодо Донбасу
Леонід Кравчук в одному з інтерв’ю українським ЗМІ.
Чи справді нова адміністрація Байдена вже розробляє такі плани?
І що про це думають за океаном?
Опитані DW американські експерти підтвердили, що Сполучені Штати
будуть діяти вже без трампівської двозначності у донбаському питанні.
Але треба обережно підходити до зміни нормандського формату,
не відкидати його і не намагатися негайно замінювати.
Коли почалася війна на Донбасі, Чарльз Купчан працював спецпомічником
президента США Барака Обами й опікувався європейськими справами,
зокрема й Україною. Часто бував у Києві та Москві.
Тоді було два паралельних напрямки: нормандський формат
і двосторонні та тристоронні переговори між США, Україною і Росією.
Одна з опцій - це продовження роботи у цих двох напрямках:
нормандський процес й американський. Інша опція - обговорення з Францією,
Німеччиною, Україною та Росією можливості створення ширшого формату
разом зі США за столом переговорів.
Це залежатиме від готовності Путіна піти на компроміс
та погодитися на припинення конфлікту.
Чи вже достатньо цього розуміння і готовності - невідомо.
Але ми знаємо, що Путін вразливий зараз через ув’язнення Навального
та протести навколо цього.
Історія свідчить, що коли Путін відчуває себе вразливим,
він подає себе крутим хлопцем за кордоном. Бо він використовує зовнішню
політику для підвищення своєї внутрішньої популярності.
Сполучені Штати продовжуватимуть надавати Україні економічну
та військову допомогу, включно з летальною зброєю.
У цьому впевнений колишній посол США в Україні, кар’єрний дипломат
Стівен Пайфер. Три роки тому  Сполучені Штати продали Україні 210 ракет
та 37 протитанкових комплексів "Джавелін".
Це відбулося за президентства Дональда Трампа.
Адміністрація його попередника Барака Обами не зважилася на цей крок,
за що критикували й Байдена, який тоді був віцепрезидентом.
Нині ж, ставши господарем Білого дому, Байден та його оточення вже
активно виступають за надання Україні летальної зброї.
В одній з останніх телефонних розмов з Києвом держсекретар США Ентоні Блінкен
заявив про готовність це зробити. Види озброєння,
обсяги поставок та інші деталі поки не розголошуються.
Одна з головних дилем для Байдена, вважає Пайфер, це "Північний потік-2".
Нова адміністрація США прагне відновити трансатлантичні партнерські
відносини з Євросоюзом, зокрема з Берліном,
які геть погіршилися за часів Трампа. Тож, експерти не виключають
тристоронньої домовленості щодо газової труби.
Адміністрація Байдена не хоче воювати з Берліном через "Північний потік-2".
Вони хочуть бути важливими партнерами. Тож, якщо вдасться зробити так,
що росіяни залишать Донбас, а США, зі свого боку, знімуть санкції з "Північного потоку-2",
це було б сприйнято позитивно. Бо санкції проти "Північного потоку-2"
не для того, щоб лише покарати Росію. Вони мають досягти політичних цілей.
Якщо це сприятиме тому, щоб Росія залишила Донбас
і він інтегрувався назад в Україну, це було б гарною домовленістю.
Чи піде на це Москва, поки неясно. Але це той підсолоджувач, який міг би допомогти.
За словами старшого експерта Атлантичної ради Аріеля Коена,
який родом з Криму й уважно стежить за подіями в Україні,
між Вашингтоном і Берліном є консенсус щодо безпеки та стабільності України,
але є й ознаки можливого загострення ситуації на Донбасі навесні.
Росія у складній економічній ситуації,
також уряд побоюється протестів… І щоб відволікти увагу,
Кремль може спробувати розхитати ситуацію, зробити гаряче.
Чи це буде велика війна? Я не думаю.
Чи зацікавленні США в ескалації з Росією? Звісно, ні.
Сполучені Штати займаються ковідною кризою та іншими внутрішніми проблемами.
І Китай нині головний пріоритет для адміністрації Байдена.
Але українському уряду та військовим варто бути
підготовленими до можливої ескалації навесні.
Про оформлену і затверджену нову стратегію США щодо Донбасу
поки говорити передчасно. Нова адміністрація Байдена лише чотири тижні
при владі. Треба почекати, поки остаточно сформується команда Байдена,
яка опікуватиметься українським питанням.
Зокрема, добре відому в Україні дипломатку Вікторію Нуланд номінували
на посаду заступника держсекретаря з політичних справ,
але ще не затвердили. Проблем з цим, за словами експертів, не має бути.
Чи призначать США нового спецпредставника Держдепу щодо України,
як колись був Курт Волкер, у Вашингтоні ще не визначилися.
Але вже очевидно, що Сполучені Штати за президентства Байдена
активніше перейматимуться Україною,
впевнені опитані DW американські експерти,
і варто очікувати більшого залучення США
до вирішення спершу донбаського питання, а потім і кримського.